being the stunt performer you're maybe
one of the coolest people on set because
we get to play for a living
8711 action design does action sequences
for film from beginning to end what we
do is we choreograph fight scenes or
action sequences and then we execute the
filming of them in the actual meeting
the performers that we have today are
incredible acrobats freerunning parkour
artists some of them have a dance
background and break dancing you need
people with extreme talents I was a
gymnast I don't have a fight background
at all I literally threw my first punch
when I stepped foot in this gym
every job is different the hunger games
it's more running and jumping something
like x-men it's more like fighting and
flipping it was sort of that passion for
martial arts that let me get into stunts
but then also to build this company
there are actors if they can do 90% of
their stunts and they can do them better
than the stunt performers I would say
Brad Pitt and Matt Damon who Jackman is
one of those freakish athletes but even
then the stunt double is essential to
how that character is it there are a lot
of tricks to the trade the stunt double
is more prominent in the film than you
really realize and there are ways to
disguise them the way you photograph
them a lot of our stuff is rigging
oriented safety wires photography that
we apply to green-screen elements that
make us look like we're in a dangerous
spot in action sequence or a fight team
if you can't see the face I would say
it's usually a stunt double most of the
time they're not hitting each other or
making contact there are accidents
sometimes where people do get hit and
yeah definitely bruised up a lot
personally I've had knee reconstruction
and I've had broken my wrist in four
places and a couple concussions it is
part of the job you accept the risk and
getting the stunts
you